[Musique]
le niveau des températures s'élevant un
peu plus que par le passé les
précipitations stagnant voire étant
légèrement plus faible on a moins
d'accumulation de nage en hiver on a un
peu plus de chaleur notamment en été
donc un peu plus de fonte ce qui veut
dire que l'équilibre globale du glacier
est plutôt mise à mal et plutôt négatif
et donc ça produit le recul glaciaire
parce qu'on vient en déficit de glace
année après année c'est ce qu'on
constate depuis déjà 10 20 ans avec
plutôt une accélération sur les
dernières années notamment liées aux été
très très chaud qu'on a qu'on a connu
récemment
[Musique]
on sait que globalement le la forme du
permafrost rend les sols en haute
altitude moins stable que par le passé
on peut plus s'implanter sur ces sols là
donc le nombre de sites permettant
l'accueil de nouvelles de nouvelles
installations et un peu plus réduits et
ça c'est une conséquence directe du
réchauffement climatique
[Musique]
parce que nous c'est vrai que moi je
suis Bretagne donc l'été c'est la mer
c'est toute l'année et l'hiver c'est la
montagne systématiquement et de voir ça
comme ça au fur et à mesure des années
ça nous inquiète parce qu'on se dit plus
tard on va faire comment avant on avait
l'habitude de venir en avril sans risque
maintenant on préfère prendre février
pour être sûr d'avoir de la neige
à cause du changement climatique on a
bien vu qu'il avait pas neigé depuis
plusieurs mois et c'est même compliqué
là sur les pistes sur certaines pistes
qui sont fermées on voit bien que il y a
un manque de neige
[Musique]
avant on avait besoin d'un de gros gants
chauds d'une d'une doudoune des
vêtements thermiques maintenant là quand
il fait 15 degrés on peut skier en pull
donc on a plus besoin de
vraiment s'habiller chaudement pour
aller au ski
shirt alors pour les touristes ils sont
ravis mais c'est vrai que quand je parle
avec eux à table et puis je leur
explique c'est pareil s'il y a pas de
neige l'été prochain on aurait pas d'eau
dans les rivières en bas donc oui
effectivement moi on va attendre saison
j'ai vu une évolution vu que ça fait 20
ans je passe mes hivers à 2000 mètres
oui je me rends compte
[Musique]